this is crazy ceo says two-thirds of
ammunition deliveries have gone missing
with ups that's a lot of ammo so where
is it now
all right maybe this is just one company
patrick collins ceo of thegunfood.com
lost thousands of dollars worth of ammo
because customers orders don't always
seem to make it to their doors
especially when delivering with ups this
is about 18 000 rounds of ammo shipped
through ups only a third were actually
delivered so where is it going okay now
hold on
one company first off eighteen thousand
rounds the ammo
so my first thought when i see this
story is particularly sensational yes
also kind of alarming if it is part of
something greater
and i think that's kind of what they're
hinting at that things are starting to
break down
so you've got now where they're gonna be
hiring 87 000 irs agents and they're
giving them hollow points
right they bought hollow points for the
irs and then gates introduced that
legislation that was like no we're not
going to give them ammunition i don't
know what you're talking about yeah so
so it's just
the reason i bring this story up is not
to insinuate that one
company seeing their ammo go missing is
indicative of a collapse but just like
it's another grain of sand in in this
heap with irs agents being armed with
taiwan that uh maybe the fourth turning
is upon us you're familiar with uh
what do you what do you what do you
think and do you think this plays
anything into it i mean
there's a lot of people i'm not sure
what i think about cycles uh
i'm generational cycles i i mean like i
know enough about physics you know all
energy moves and waves and cycles so
it's almost certainly the uh the it
seems they seem to make a lot of sense
right um
i don't know uh and then fourth turning
is just one of many different historical
cycle type things
i i don't think you have to know
anything about cycles just look around
and be like a lot of [ __ ] is hitting a
lot of fans right now what do you think
happens to a city like new york if the
supply chain just
was halting all right well here's okay
so
not this past winter but two winters ago
i can tell you what happens to a city
like austin when the supply chain is
because i was there for the winter
apocalypse you guys remember yes yeah
okay so like i grew up driving in you
know i spent seven years in chicago i
know how to drive in snow and no one in
texas did because it's all texans
californians my my first year in dallas
i remember having to drive everyone
around because i couldn't do it i have
no idea and so it snowed a lot and so
for seven days
basically everyone was locked in but
really for four days everything was
truly down
by the end of the by the beginning of
the fourth day one of uh the people who
worked i was still at my company who
worked for my company she was she lived
like eight blocks from the office was
walking into the office right
um because we were all remote so like we
keep working sh she had people trying to
rob her but like these are clearly not
professionals it was like a dude who was
hungry right and i mean
my top my company was
75 people full-time in austin at that
point and they were all like millennials
who were like lol i have cheetos in my
freezer i don't know what that's all i
have like i had to drive i just got in a
cow slaughter and so i literally drove
like 200 pounds of meat in to the office
and then a bunch of them walked in to
get it dude [ __ ] went nuts there there
was five and six hour lines to get like
a bag of pasta yeah it like it was bad
man and this is just this wasn't even
like thought the grid didn't go grid
kind of went down a little bit but like
it was bad this is what i'm talking
about when when i tell people like when
i do a pitch for for emergency food i'm
talking about this yes and like
sometimes it rains yes but but you get
all these these leftists that are like
mocking the idea and then when it
actually
happens is one thing this is why i think
they're going to eat each other like
it's going to be and that's like
bro but i think part of you see that you
see the new york times already saying
the time for cannibal or whatever
they're writing about it listen go ahead
have fun you're in new york i'll eat
your neighbor
i don't care no seriously i don't if
they want to eat your neighbor no if you
want to belong to a death cult then you
get to reap the consequences i don't i
don't belong to that i've prepared i'm
around a bunch of great people who are
all ready to i don't need to worry about
like that's like zombies like you know
but but i mean literally if you have
people who live in new york city they've
got no they've prepared for nothing
there's clearly signs indicating
something is hitting us right now the
food supply we've been told over and
over again since the start of the year
president said right press conference
and they're still mocking the idea that
they would do any kind of preparation
and so i'm just like
it's a zombie horde they don't think for
themselves they don't care to solve
problems they are just standing there in
the crowd mindless and then quite
literally yo
if the supply chain collapses and you
get 2.5 million people on manhattan
island alone let alone central brooklyn
how do you get out of central brooklyn
you don't no stay there but no no but i
mean like
stay there you're gonna have to try to
get out there's not gonna be food and
people are gonna be it's gonna be it's
gonna be nightmarish yeah no i mean like
you like it's it'll get
it'll get uh abandoned prison camp bad
yep like what like
maybe five days i wouldn't be surprised
if you see slavery
oh way past that yeah i mean roving
gangs warlords like it doesn't take long
to get there in a true grid down
situation what do they say you're three
meals away from a revolution three like
that no 12 missed meals well it's like a
saying it's like i think it's 12 96
hours and 12 minutes meals is that what
it is i think
and then people just start uh losing it
yeah and then also where to eat your
water from see here out here there's a
river
and uh we also we have a creek as well
and then so we can we can go out and
great and then and then i've got
emergency filters and i've got other
stuff but we also have a well
we got a well
yeah and so if if if everything went
south and the grid shut down or whatever
it's i'd be like just another old day i
guess we got tons of backup batteries
we've got a massive solar backup system
at the new facility we're building but
people in these cities
when when covet happened they're locked
in their apartments they have no food
and they're losing their minds yeah it's
crazy like a stress test
well we just saw it in shanghai
yeah like they went on a hard hard
lockdown and no one knows how many
people died there you know chinese are
real sketchy about that but all those
videos coming out people were like
you see the pictures of people taking
the refrigerator the guy takes the
refrigerator and pushes it onto his
balcony it's open and empty
because they had no food
people were losing it
i remember when um
it was sandy hurricane sandy oh in new
york
that was bad i was in new york and it
was crazy to see how high the flood
waters got windows were smashed out from
the surge the coolest thing i saw was
when the downed bus stops skateboarders
were grinding on them so they were
having a blast but then you go to the
bodegas there's no electricity so all
the perishables have expired within a
couple days
and i went in there were two guys
outside holding like two by fours a big
line
and they were like one person at a time
i walked in cash only obviously and the
guy was just like he's like
don't touch the perishables like the
milk everything's bad you don't eat it
but anything that's not perishable like
the the high fructose corn juice
and like the canned stuff is good and so
i went and i was like i got like a coke
and i was like it's warm
you know but it's all you get yo
and the other thing too is people don't
realize how quickly it's gonna go to
like
to the 1800s no more cold drinks no more
ice no more ice cream no more flushing
the toilet
nope
you're going back in time real quick
yeah and then the question becomes how
long does it last oh for them that that
so i'd put it this way
new york
gets supply chain disruption like the
whole system just just fails for some
reason
you get a couple days where it's guys
two by fours guarding the bodegas and
people going in
three days after that the food's gone
yeah and now it's people fighting in the
streets with last can of beans three
days after that people have already
started to leave they're gonna be eating
fish out of the hudson and they're gonna
be barfing and sick the entire time but
i think the other thing that happens and
this we saw this during covet is those
who can like wealthy people who can
afford to move more quickly will move
into upstate new york connecticut parts
of new jersey and then continue to put
pressure on those systems that don't
normally have that many people there so
those grocery stores will start to feel
the effect you know what you're missing
is after the ritual might go fast but
then what happens you know you hit days
five to ten when all the stores are
empty if nothing's coming in what
happens is people start moving out and
not the rich people the people everyone
has to go walking out yep and not a few
of them but manhattan isn't highlands or
hundreds of thousands so you've got a
few bridges and tunnels right that's it
bottlenecking the whole i know did you
see how they put it's so weird to talk
about this because they just put those
massive metal doors on um
uh the tunnels on the lincoln tunnel yes
they call them flood tunnels but they're
not flood tunnels they're getting ready
to lock everybody
i think so i know it sounds crazy to
even talk about this it sounds lunacy
but they just like i saw it was like a
month ago wouldn't it yeah lincoln
tunnel has one and i think the midtown
tunnel
i think all of them maybe what do i
search for flood doors yeah flood doors
lincoln tunnel but what about how do
they stop the bridges you know i oh yeah
look at this i'm not sure
there you go yeah this is a couple years
ago actually
no i so one of them like i know 44
600 pound floodgates installed in nyc
tunnels to protect from super storms
maybe it's because of sandy they were
like it's not unthinkable yeah it's not
it does both yeah stops the water and
the people yeah you can go north out of
manhattan i mean there's still rivers to
the to the west but yeah you can you can
walk north there's no it just goes up
you can walk but like if things are in
that much chaos how far are you really
going to get on foot oh man
a leak in the lincoln tunnel in 2020
people were freaking out so it could be
why but i do think it's funny that they
put up these big barriers i know dude
bottlenecks is going to be like you know
you see the batman movie where the the
cops block all the bridges and like
nobody leaves the city
i don't know yeah i don't know i don't
you know look
when we were talking about world war one
the other day the crazy thing is people
don't realize how quickly things fall
apart yeah yeah and it was just like
grass was it gradually then suddenly
yeah yeah i think that people
underestimate
how quickly things can fall apart
because they're told to sort of live for
now and live for impulsively i think
this is a lot of like left-leaning
culture that you wouldn't think ahead
like when you say like people make fun
of people who are acquiring food because
they're like oh what do you think it's
gonna be a doomsday it's gonna be a
purge all at once like no not
necessarily but also you can't think
past the two days in front of you
because
the impulsivity culture and the
self-indulgence culture tells you that
it's not worth dealing with well that
and then also i mean like in 2019 i made
fun of preppers and i didn't really i
had a couple guns but they're like
hunting like i wasn't
you've converted oh to a hundred percent
of course and well how could you not
after the last two and a half years
right but i think it's also that like
we've grown up in
arguably the richest most abundant
safest period in world history in the
safest country in the world so it's like
who alive has had to deal with anything
truly
catastrophic like we don't i don't know
you know and so like the idea that this
could happen is just not it's not in the
living memory of anybody right now
yeah we we've had
uh
golden ages of sorts at least from our
perspective we've been
the security has been fat and happy fat
and happy i know we've had problems i
know there's been a recession i know
there's been 9 11 things like that come
on man we've been fa as a culture and as
a country you've been as fat and happy
as it gets
and and growing fatter by the day i mean
now they're now you know you know where
body positivity comes from
you you say of course it's because more
too many people because everyone's fat
so they're all now agreeing with each
other that we're we're just looking to
do this yeah exactly okay go ahead that
works for you they got that store that
what morbid
morbid touring oh yeah toward no i call
it more but on purpose i was gonna say
did they really call it morgan torrid
i call it morbid close enough she's
gonna buy it call it that and be like
still shop there no i was i was thinking
of of opening a store and calling it
morbid and it would just be like huge
clothes chunkers chompers
but that's a meme so that's okay right
but that's america that's america so i
guess my question my next question is
like how many days until people are
eating each other in new york
like the tunnels are closed and they're
banging on the door and they can't get
out
there's no food
there is i can't remember i read a book
about survival that had like a like a
chart i think it's i think it's under
it's way faster than i thought it's
under two weeks
i can't remember the three days
no
not three days they started each other
that's that's a pretty big taboo to
cross
that would have to be i think that's in
week two but not by the end of week i
don't that's why i don't i feel like
week two i mean
you're you can go a month without food
right
but i guess most people can't when your
muscles start breaking down you're just
and there's gonna be so much panic
people are gonna feel the desperation
sooner than if they were intentionally
you know what you know what would happen
though i bet the first person to get
eaten it's not going to be like some
dude just goes i'm sorry i'm hungry and
like hit somebody it's going to be like
somebody falls down and gets trampled
and then they're like well let's eat
yeah yeah let's eat like you said like
hey it's like the lord of the rings
meats are back on the menu boys
dude it's nightmarish to think about the
stuff that's why we got like 50 chickens
no that's why i have two cows and the
flock of sheep 24 sheep and i was i was
reading about bugs and then what's the
protein called chitin is that what it's
called i don't know
i'm not gonna eat the bugs that's their
carapace it's made of that stuff yeah
and i was reading you can't digest it
it's like chitin or whatever yeah
you just you can't digest it and so
that's why you let the chickens eat it
yes and then you eat the chickens or the
eggs you eat the eggs and then when time
comes you eat the chicken yeah and then
it's amazing here's the best part
chickens they make more of themselves
that's crazy they replicate they
replicate and they just eat the grass
and you've got to make sure nothing else
eats them and then you get to eat them
yep and it tastes good yup you were
talking about like how our society
doesn't have a story right now yeah i'm
a kind of obsessive about talking about
new technology like you know graphene
industry and iron fertilization of the
oceans regrowing the coral reefs and
things like that yeah sometimes it's
really about how you introduce the ideas
because like if we're in a the moment of
all like blackpilling each other like
we're waiting it's not tech i promise
you that's not the story tech might be
amazing and it might help us in a
million ways but the the general feeling
from most people is that that that god
has failed then the other idea is
monotheism and god and the unification
of the consciousness but like i almost
feel like i'm selling out when i do that
yeah you know there's something to be
said for that man like uh i i was ex
i've been an atheist my whole life and
then i did psychedelic medicine like as
a therapy and i was like oh [ __ ] i'm
totally wrong of course god exists it's
just not in the way that religious dogma
talks about it's more of a all things
what
that might be but that that story that
might be a little airy fairy for at
least right now i think generally
revivals generally happen after people
have suffered a lot we're going into the
suffering phase not fourth turning phase
yeah
2028 should be fun though
six more years i'll be in my 40s i don't
know i think we got at least a decade
there's a lot of unraveling to happen i
kind of like what's what's the worst
case in there for somebody
for someone who lives out in the middle
of nowhere i mean asteroids strike no no
i mean like society collapsing
like this is really important living out
in the middle of nowhere by yourself
you're actually not you're better off
than in a city not a great spot
like being in a in the country with a
community that's the better spot like
where you you're not
way off by yourself you're actually an
easy target you know and you don't have
anyone around to help you know whereas
if it's like us and like eight neighbors
or you kind of know your neighbors
that's a different situation the
fortress around you don't necessarily
have to have a fortress like it doesn't
have to be a castle right you just have
to kind of know dude i i joke about like
one day we'll be we'll be hanging out
we'll be doing the show and we'll hear
like a noise and then we'll like run
outside and there'll be some hipster guy
and like flannel with a beanie on a
handlebar mustache trying to steal a
chicken and he's like i'm just hungry
and we're like stop him chase him down
he like absolutely like brooklyn dude in
texas all you you paint your fence posts
purple and you put no trespassing sign
because that's basically the you know if
you come on land we're gonna shoot you
purple yeah purple that's like the color
that is purple heart why is that i don't
know it did that just pick that
color color and like deoxygenated blood
no dude one like one of the weird things
about texas like animal rustling you
could you just shoot like if if you like
if you have animals in the field then
you've you know posted and whatever and
someone's in there
like no you're that's where you can
shoot them in the back it doesn't matter
you're not going to prison yeah like you
don't steal animals in texas you get
shot it's bad
yeah i'm sure those laws go way back
do you think that i that we because i
think we are building the story for the
future right now maybe nothing we say
today is gonna cause it to change
tomorrow but in 20 years when people are
like i've had enough right they'll look
at this video right and that will be
what inspires them right what do you
think like psychedelics god no i mean
psychedelics are just a tool i'm not
like i like psychedelics i use them as
medicine like they've been
transformative for me but i'm not like
you know uh bless his heart like i love
aubrey marcus but i'm like oh you got
everyone's got to do ayahuasca no
everyone doesn't you know like they're
just a tool to achieve a goal they're
not the thing like imagine if i was
super into hammers like what what why
but if i'm like i want to build a lot of
houses for people live in you're like oh
okay that makes sense so i just look at
psychedelics as the hammer right i kind
of i've always kind of felt that there's
a lot of people who really need some
kind of
hammer experience hammer that's one way
to put it because i don't want to
hammers are important but but i don't
wanna
i don't mean just like one thing like
dmt or something like that but i think a
lot of people are like locked in their
minds they can't they can't see outside
the box it really shocked me awake with
the first time i took mushrooms i was
walking around manhattan beach and uh
looking at it it was trash night and i
was like where does this trash go what
have you done as a species you needed
mushrooms we're just yeah we're just
like oh but that's the point but it hit
my core it changed my core like it
changed my dna and the way i was
perceiving it this is exactly what i
mean yeah right from for me i remember
you know i would talk to my friends and
they would start asking these crazy
philosophical questions or like when
they were stoned or something and i was
like i don't need whatever it is you're
doing to ask these questions but clearly
you do
maybe there are some people who are like
mindless cogs but then they they have an
experience like ian was saying and also
they started asking themselves where's
that garbage going then they realized
hey wait a minute probably not somewhere
good just like so many problems they're
just putting in on an island and waiting
for it to go away they put on a garbage
bar you kick it out and forget about it
of course there's now we find there's
mushrooms and bacteria that'll digest it
and turn it into sugar there's lots of
cleansing
some of it is with substances it takes
away the inhibition people may think
about this thing on some level but they
don't want to ask so they don't want to
be the only one they want to blend in
and not but but ian asked himself
right but you were saying your friends
are posing these questions to you while
you're hanging out there's like a
there's like a desensitization without
the psychedelics like real like right
now you're kind of blending into the
wall i see like the scene but when i'm
on psilocybin you stand out life is very
different than non-life it becomes very
apparent that we have created this thing
or someone before me built this freaking
set that we're on and now
you may wake up one day and you're here
and you're like stuff that exists it
creates a value for for life i think um
at least psilocybin did for me i think a
big problem one of the big problems
we've had is that millennials
and to an extent every generation before
it but growing in scale don't understand
that other people did work to make
things exist that you have so like for
example i remember i was riding my bike
across the williamsburg bridge
in new york and i just thought to myself
like man
some people worked really really hard to
make this bridge happen and i don't
think twice when i ride my bike over it
i don't pay for it i have no i mean i
got city taxes cover the costs but it's
just there well one day there was some
dude or some lady and they were just
like yo we need a bridge and then all
these humans were like
let's work really really hard and and
and sweat and tears and probably a lot
of people died in construction and now
all these people are just like what do
you mean the bridge is just there and
it's like you don't you don't understand
the value of what was gifted to you just
and and the thing about the bridge is
you could be a tourist and you get free
use of it
like you're not paying anything for this
it's just there and you get it i think
that is like the generational wealth of
millennials and and now gen z they don't
understand how much blood sweat and
tears went into making the world so
comfortable so
i don't think any young people do i
didn't understand when i was 25. i'm not
sure if it's that generation
specifically i'm more gen x i guess and
like i was a [ __ ] idiot 25 yeah what
the hell is it
yeah right and i know my parents were
because they're still idiots in their
70s right so like yeah
i mean i think in ayahuasca no yeah
we need people to get access to their
ancestral knowledge what i'm talking
about
you mentioned earlier you don't think
the technology is the
story but like
in the past the story was told through
new technology like the printing press
allowed us to proliferate the story of
or writing allowed us to proliferate the
idea of god to the masses so maybe that
the metaverse or that the internet is
the is the vessel that the story will be
told so the post-world war ii story in
america was that progress
solves all and progress is the goal
where has that gotten us
modern monetary theory what is progress
it was
the the story coming out of world war ii
was that progress the american story is
a story of progress right
i i that it's just prog but like
the
it's like the the the concept of growth
for the sake of growth is the philosophy
of cancer right progress just to make
progress because it's technical
technological progress is serving a
different god it is not serving humans
right whereas like i would contrast that
to
like an idea that could and i mean a
meta idea that could replace that would
be prosperity what does prosperity for
humans look like because it does not
always in fact rarely does it mean more
technology in fact more technology is
usually antithetical to prosperity for
humans it might be great for
owners god i sound like a goddamn
marxist right now but it's
and i'm not
all i really am not i can't stand them
interesting philosophy but but if they
honestly if there was one thing karl
marx got right it was at least the
beginning of a critique of understanding
that that that there is a relationship
between a human and the value they
create that matters that's not captured
in the normal way you calculate capital
right and so like what is wrong with
your show you're getting me to defend
the system it marks up going crazy i
know yeah this is not been called no but
but process like i'm a big believer now
like
in
the way to measure
anything is how does this benefit humans
humans not stakeholder capitalism and
that's all nonsense that's all a scam to
screw people but like how am i better
how is my neighbors better how's my
family better how my kids are better how
am i animals better right
and like i like technology when it
serves humans and prosperity but like
a lot of it doesn't man thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there